this episode of the minimalist is
brought to you by
nobody because
oh yes
well welcome minimizers to the
minimalist podcast my name is joshua
fields milburn and i'm ryan nicodemus
and together we are the minimalists wow
we're here in salt lake city
oh you guys i gotta be honest with you
so
so
well a few things one is i accidentally
wore these pants that have a hole in the
crotch
and it's the only pair of pants i have
one so i have two pairs of pants and
this is the only one i brought with me
so
thankfully ryan and i share a pair of
underwear and i'm actually wearing the
pair today
thank god
here's my other confession for you
though
legitimately salt lake city is my
favorite city in the country
[Applause]
now
and i would live here if you didn't have
winter
i'm dead serious i would totally live
here now i've been a big fan of the utah
jazz since i was a little kid
which sounds really weird from this
kid from from dayton ohio why did he
grow up liking the utah jazz
well my brother's black so we used to
pretend we were stockton and malone
whenever we played basketball and that's
really the only reason and it has stuck
ever since
but also you have you're so blessed to
have something that you probably don't
even realize you have you you saw nate
and scott up here earlier
and there's sort of half of this band
that they formed to make the soundtracks
to both of our films there's this band
called vve or wii there's actually an
argument between the members of the band
itself whether it's called we or vve so
you can call it whatever you want i
guess
but um
but thanks to nate i mean he won't take
credit for this but you have
what is legitimately the best
independent music scene in the country
here in utah yeah absolutely
and um when ryan and i lived in montana
i would all the time make the eight hour
drive down here just to go to a concert
and then drive back sometimes the same
night
um and
you're you're just really fortunate i
mean it's not it's just you already know
this it's the most beautiful place there
is and then also some of the most
amazing people on earth i i'm stalling
long enough now we have a microphone
here if anyone wants to approach it now
i could keep going on about how much i
love salt lake city but it looks like we
have some questions here i was hoping
we'd talk about the john stockton statue
but maybe another time oh yeah we i mean
josh treats it like a buddha statue he
goes there every time he puts a little
coin
on i'm just kidding he does not do that
what else i have really long underwear
is that a thing i mean i
i've even dated a few mormon girls
not at the same time
although i'm open to that as well
it looks like we have some questions
here howdy what's your name
hi
hi my name is julia
julia yes julia hi it's nice to meet you
nice to meet you nice to meet you what's
on your mind um well i just don't have a
question but i have a confession to make
[Laughter]
i love when these events just turn into
confessions
[Laughter]
i throw out my kids toys all the time
i have five kids and i do have an
internal struggle with every time i do
it
but
you know
it just i talk to them quite often but i
don't think they
can comprehend quite well about what i'm
trying to say and they're not willing to
let go and at the same time i'm the
parent and i have to make some choices
for them and also it's my house as well
sure yeah so and that's the internal
struggle i have maybe you have some kind
of tips of yeah let's talk about it you
mean your like four-year-old can't
understand the idea of an opportunity
cost
[Laughter]
let me explain i tried to do this to my
daughter ella when she was three i was
trying to explain uh delayed
gratification to her
and one time she just looked at her mom
she goes i don't understand what he's
saying
so here's the thing um do you like do
you chew up their food and spit into
their mouth
no
okay um
yeah and the reason i don't do that with
my daughter either is because sometimes
she has to learn how to do some things
on her own
and um
by getting rid of her stuff for her by
getting rid of anyone's stuff for them
which by the way if you uh go home and
get rid of your partner stuff that's
called theft so um i know some of you
were dragged here tonight like who the
hell are these guys and
um we're not encouraging you to get rid
of other people's stuff in fact uh i
would discourage that because it will
make the relationship much more tense
and i think the same thing is actually
true with our children
our friend rob bell says that we're
always teaching our children sometimes
it's with words and so of course you
could tell them about um what were you
opportunity costs and and in delayed
gratification and and and
telling them that even when they're at
an age to understand it they only
understand it intellectually they don't
understand it in in their heart in their
viscera right and so
i tell you i've
i've had two really proud moments
as a father in um
the last eight years
not a great batting average
um but i remember one when ella was five
and i've never told her to get rid of
her things
but she came to me one day she we have
this donation box by our front door
and once a month we just take it over to
the donation store
and let them sort out the stuff
and um one day she came to me and her
mom with just this pile of toys and she
said
hey
i'm not playing with this anymore and i
think
i think some other kid
would really enjoy playing with these
toys
now why did she do that well because
she's seen us do this over and over and
over yes as the minimalist we still get
rid of stuff right i haven't got down to
the magical perfect number of items
sometimes i acquire things they stop
adding value to my life so i let them go
and she's seen us let them go
and when she asks why are you getting
rid of it i explain well we're not
getting value from anymore it's actually
getting in the way but someone else
might be able to get value from it now
that's way easier to just
go into her room once a month and and
take the toys out for her but i'm not
doing her
well i wouldn't be doing her i'd be
doing her disservice
by not teaching her through
the actions
and so
if anything
if you want your kids to have a better
understanding of contribution of letting
go
of the tug of consumerism it's through
modeling it yourself
and eventually you can help them right
you can set boundaries for sure
right but the reason they have so many
toys they didn't go out and buy them
right
you've let them come into your house now
some people gave them to you because
gift giving is a love language
another lie we've been we've been sold
right literally um
and uh
and so people are heaping gifts upon you
plus we bring stuff in plus you know
what it's just easier for me to say yes
sometimes yes go ahead and get it fine
there's a story in the book
where um
you know whenever you leave a museum you
have to what exit through the gift shop
it's a bit ironic that we have books on
the way out of this
josh everything we do is steeped in
irony
everything if you do happen to pick up a
book please minimize it afterward
the book will show you how to let it go
that's a good like title for a book
actually
all right anyway uh
you know you have to exit through a gift
shop and so like every time i'd go to a
museum with with my daughter she would
say yeah we go in there like there's
this consumer frenzy there's so much
stimulation right after like really calm
nice art museum and she'd be running
through the uh the gift shop hey can i
get
can i
can i get something
i'm like
what do you want
i don't know anything
i say ask me tomorrow
she never asked me tomorrow because it's
right there in the moment and
so i can explain delay i can explain
delayed gratification to her or i can
show her what it actually is
most recently we um
we went to the van gogh exhibit that was
in la
it was wonderful and of course at the
end we had to exit through the gift shop
this is my second proud fatherly moment
and as we're exiting instead of can i
get something anything she looked around
at all these mugs and mouse pads who the
hell uses a mouse pad
um
and and and you know like faux paintings
and
pins and
glowing sparkly things with van gogh's
name on it
and she looks up at me and she goes
do you
do you think van gogh would like his art
on all of these things
thanks for your question
thank you appreciate you being here
thanks julia
what's your name
hi guys my name is glenn
it's great to see you guys up close i
had to look twice to make sure
ryan had uh
it wasn't barefoot
he is wearing shoes yeah for sure my
feet sweat so much and then these like
they're just nice and breezy and
can't really wear them in the wintertime
anyway what's your question
um i've used your guys advice in the
past
and it's it's helped me to get over
and let go of bad relationships
um but this time i'm coming to you
needing help getting uh well letting go
of a good one that i did i didn't
necessarily want to end
wow
wow
um so you've had a relationship did it
end recently yeah yeah how recent
uh about a month ago oh wow
man
and this person broke up with you
yeah yeah
yeah
man
ryan you've been broken up with a lot
dude it actually it made me think of
this i have yeah it's true i mean it's
funny thank you for laughing at my
expense
that's what a good best friend does
you know yeah
i had this it was like
the summer of 2013 missoula montana
i was like i don't know 32 years old it
was like i didn't have the best summer
of my life until i was in my 30s it was
unbelievable
and there was this girl i was dating
um and i was just like head over heels
and um it lasted about a week
turns out she was you know just a
man-eater you know you know that song it
was written about her anyway
um and it broke my freaking heart but
you know i i'll try to think of
something pithy here but you know
i really that like even though it was
just like a week
every single day that week we were we
were doing something we were hanging out
yeah it just
it just uh ended pretty abruptly but i
was able to look at that time and
appreciate
just the opportunity because i would
have rather have had that week than
nothing at all like if you were to come
to me at the beginning of the week be
like dude you're going to have the best
week of your life
um but then she's going to break up with
you i'd be like bring it on let's do it
so
there there is something with the able
to have the gratitude for the time i did
have and i learned a lot from that
relationship as well so
uh just carrying that lesson to with
with me into the future helped me to
avoid
some similar pains and situations and
i'll continue thinking some of the
empathy as josh answers
i've something pithy for you but then
we'll talk about it
first off i'm sorry man um
i know i know what grieving is like in
fact there's a great book called
grieving is loving
by dr joanne cacciatore she's gonna be
with us in two days in phoenix
and um that's where i would start if
you're looking for
if you're looking to better understand
your grieving and why
suppressing it doesn't help in fact it
does the opposite
that's where i'd start there's also a
wonderful book called
the way to love by anthony demello
here's my pithy answer for you though
to let go is to love
now letting go involves what
well it's not something you do
letting go of something you stop doing
you stop clinging now when ryan and i
are talking about letting go it's
usually in the
the context of your material possessions
right and so we're clinging to these
things and
and
the moment i let go of it i actually
don't do anything
i just stop
clinging
now in
terms of a relationship it's a little
bit different right because there isn't
a physical thing to cling to
but don't we cling to people
we cling to toxic relationships
we cling to the way we wish things were
but that's not love that's attachment
that's not good or bad so i'm not saying
you know
one now one might be preferable to you
but it's much harder
to stop holding on because we've been
programmed for so long
that to love someone is to try to change
them
to need them every love song talks about
how much i need you in my life baby
that's not love
that's clinging
and so
the reason that it hurts so much it's
because
well we had a particular expectation
ryan had an expectation when he went
into that relationship and if his
expectation would have been like hey
this is over in a week
but it probably actually been more fun
yeah you're right i would have like
soaked it in more we have a really good
friend ryan got his packing party idea
from our friend colin wright
and um
well because colin he was living with
his girlfriend for about a year or two
and they were in seattle
and they decided hey we want to go down
different paths now sort of mutually
decided and so together they had a
breakup party
and they scheduled it a month in advance
and they he said that was the best month
of their relationship
because they knew that
wow
this thing is almost over
but it's almost over y'all
you think you have so much time
it's
it's ending right now every moment
is ending
and we don't enjoy any of them because
we're staring in that rear view mirror
or we're looking off
staring at some hypothetical horizon in
a distant future that i hope happens one
day
well that hope is going to hurt you
i'm not telling you not to have hope
but when we're really here in the moment
there's no need for it there's no need
for an expectation of the future
we can enjoy this
right now we can enjoy the person we're
with
right now
he had that breakup party and at
midnight they
they switched their facebook statuses to
single
and they moved on and for a long time he
spent the next
several years traveling to a new country
every four months and he didn't even
pick the country his readers on his blog
voted where he went next they'd go to
argentina or india or iceland
or wherever else in the world he was
he ended up in wichita once
yeah and um he was only there for four
months at a time
and every relationship he had was
meaningful intimate or otherwise
because there was an expiration date on
spoiler alert there's an expiration date
on all of your relationships
and if we start realizing that
then maybe we can actually love
the people who are in front of us
instead of expecting something out of
them
that's a little bit longer than 140
characters
yeah you can clap for that
nice
yeah that was
man when i had that realization of like
like truly this really felt
uh how long have humans been around and
like none of us may get out of here
alive
and like it was the most joyous sadness
i've ever had in my life
because it helped me appreciate the
moments that i do have and it was glenn
right glenn here's the pithy answer i'll
give to you is uh the person's love you
need the most is your own
[Music]
that's good yeah thanks for that
question howdy hello we saved the best
for last
what's your name i'm hedy it rhymes with
spaghetti hedy likes spaghetti yeah
nice to meet you nice to meet you honey
spaghetti
okay
um but first i just want to say thanks
for being here um i appreciate you guys
being here and i'm grateful that i get
the chance to be here live because in
person's always better
um but yeah so my uh i guess i'll start
off by saying i listened to your
shopping
addiction podcast that just came out
today
yeah i'm like a good little asian
student i like get right on it
me too
you know
so it like really resonated and i am
definitely guilty of trying to
seek like that thing just around the
bend that'll make me feel whole or
complete or make me cooler or a better
person or something
and
i have been trying to kind of like
create an understanding behind this the
last couple of years
and
i understand that ultimately it boils
down to why and within that why kind of
stems into two different things
understanding the why of okay why do i
do this
and creating an understanding of your
habits and then the other side of that
is
i suppose
creating an awareness as to
why
you want to change it and what you want
to gain from changing that
and i understand that there's those two
things and i've tried to you know work
on both of them i'm sure there's a lot
more i can do but
i guess i'm just feeling stuck
and i feel like
i might be missing like this light bulb
moment or the flick of a switch where
it's like okay so now i can finally
become
an intentional minimal person
and i'm like wondering if that's just
the wrong way to go about it is it
i guess my question is is
is it something that has a moment or is
it something that gains momentum
like a snowball well clearly it's the
wrong way for you because you haven't
gotten where you want to go right
yep
um and then i guess the other option is
maybe it's not even something that you
like attain or get there it's not a
destination but it's more so like and do
i need to is it that i need to
cultivate a completely different mindset
and like practice consistency in that
and that
through that it becomes a snowball
effect sorry i don't know if that's like
a clear question nah you've been
programmed with a lot of words
well you know like the pit the answer
that comes to my mind is is like you
cannot think your way out of chaos
yeah like that's good
you cannot think your way out of chaos
like the only way
the only way to to
get the desire that you're talking about
is to develop that desire if you're
gonna if you're waiting around for that
desire to just hit you one day you'll be
waiting your whole life i heard the
words practice and try and do
and i hear a lot of sort of i hear the
gears in your head they're turning and
you're trying to figure out the sort of
equation right but this isn't math it's
poetry
and and so
here's something pithy for you but let's
talk about this for a bit because we're
all here right now we can we can talk
about it because this is a problem that
everyone struggles with right you're
much farther along than most people
you're getting stuck though because
you're tripping over your brain
and so um
here's the pithy thing
because i heard about the trying the
practice and
and the
doing
doing less isn't about
the doing
it's about the less
and so
hetty you're already there
you're trying to get somewhere where you
already are
and
so happiness doesn't come from addition
it always is found from subtraction
right
now i'm not talking about the things
that could be part of it right but just
getting rid of the things isn't going to
make you happier right
but maybe it maybe it clears the space
to realize like oh yeah you know what i
don't have to do those things that i've
been programmed to do right you by the
way you've been programmed your whole
life
to
well yeah i heard the word practice in
there right
well think of when do we practice
like who who generally practices
when you think of a person practicing
what are they doing
sports yeah they're dribbling a
basketball or throwing a football or
hitting a tennis ball or whatever right
elite athletes don't practice though
the most elite athletes
they simply
they understand
they know what compels them
and so
what is the problem why are you seeking
through
why are you seeking happiness through
things or achievements or whatever else
is because something more compelling
hasn't been put in front of you yet
but as soon as you put something more
compelling than the stuff
then the acquiring than the ch achieving
as soon as you have something more
compelling in front of you
all the other stuff will take care of
itself the how to the practice the
commitment these are all nonsense words
that were sold by sort of self-help
people who don't know any better they've
also been programmed so it's not their
fault it's not even your fault
you've been programmed by a culture that
encourages you to practice and do more
and get things
done
but everyone getting everything done is
miserable
and so yeah get all the things done and
see what kind of misery it brings you
what flavor of misery do you want
or
you can let go
and you can put something in front of
you
that you're enthused by that you're
thrilled by something that makes you
feel so alive
and if you put that in front of you
you don't need commitment
i'm not committed to my wife
what does that mean i think i can't
believe i have to be in this
relationship just one more day
i'm gonna get through today one day at a
time
no
i'm not committed to writing
i do it because i'm compelled to do it
here's a question for you what's the
thing you can't not do if you can find
that
everything else will seem so trivial you
won't want to do it
awesome thanks eddie thank you so much
thank you so much
hey minimizers ryan and i really hope
you enjoyed that minimal episode of the
minimalist podcast live in salt lake
city if you'd like to come to one of our
live events it's our favorite thing that
we do you can find all 20 cities for the
love people use things tour over at the
minimalists.com
tour find a city nearest you us and
canada or if you can't make it to any of
those events don't worry you can check
out our live events all 20 of them will
make their way over to our patreon page
patreon.com the minimalists including
this thursday we've got a maximal
episode it's the full salt lake city
event nearly two hours of minimalism we
go in depth with some of these questions
we want to share that with you this
thursday you can join us and then join
us for future episodes as well over
there at patreon.com
slash the minimalists if you subscribe
you become a supporter not only do you
keep this podcast a hundred percent
advertisement free but you get access to
hundreds of hours of private archives
you get our monthly ask the minimalist
anything sessions and our private
community of thousands of open-minded
minimizers just like you you can follow
the minimalists on facebook twitter and
instagram at the minimalists come to one
of our live podcast shows at
minimalists.com
tour
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip email a voice memo to
podcasts at theminimalists.com
comment on this episode at youtube.com
the minimalist and if you want our show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com
you'll also receive our simple sunday
newsletter for free and if you leave
here today with just one message let it
be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
[Music]
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine
without it